this episode is brought to you by Buffy
you can check out their latest product
the breeze a comforter made entirely
from a hundred percent eucalyptus fiber
to regulate temperature keep you cool
and comfortable all night long for $20
off your Buffy comforter this visit
Buffy dot co into into the code
mood ooh speaking of mood welcome back
to big we're here all of us are here
you've got the whole gang sometimes some
of us are missing but do you want to go
down the line for those people that
don't see the video they're just
listening on audio this is Nikki this is
Jess this is your boy Bo's this is TIFF
this is Gina totally normal Gina is so
normal for those of you not watching the
video she's not a creeper at all she's
very very enjoying it complaining being
stroked episode your picture your Papa
Oh innocent put your boots away very
innocence imagine your father in a photo
frame and a hallway and my dad frames
you [ __ ] that's weird recently uh
everybody knows that r.i.p Kobe Bryant
we lost a good one but after his passing
it it came out that he had a lot of
stories of being a proud girl dad and so
people that had had exchanges with Kobe
were recalling their memories of just
how proud he was to be a girl dad and
how he just wanted more and more and
more girls and I guess that took a lot
of people by surprise because most
especially if you're an athlete they
tend to want boys and they want like to
raise their athlete boys and so it was
just really cool that Kobe really loved
having daughters and he had four more
daughters yeah and he wanted like time
or yeah so he was like you're all going
into the WNBA you're all gonna be like
me you're all gonna kill it
nothing about him though he didn't even
trip about like pushing basketball on
any of his daughters that's why when GG
really loved it it was like yeah I get
to pass on like the basketball knowledge
to one of my daughters
yes so I guess that just reminded us of
like our relationships with our own
fathers because we all obviously have
girl dads and how different it was like
amongst all of us so yeah Gina was
talking a little bit about how she has a
picture of her dad in her bedroom I
don't think I have a picture of my dad
at all in my house very very different
relationships with our fathers but we'll
get there ya know I'm I'm like the
quintessential daddy's girl yeah I
always will be I'll be like 60 years old
not be like that he can have cookie no
you have an American accent about my dad
so the reason why we're so close is
because I never grew up with him I've
never lived with my dad um the most time
I've spent with him consecutively was
probably like six months and then he had
to move away to another state so being
away from him made me like in my 20s
when I started making more money and
like I can fly and go see my dad and
like when you're not like a [ __ ]
little kid anymore I'm like oh man I
miss my dad I want a relationship with
him so it was always like hey how are
you but then now when I started making
money I'm like okay dad am I gonna visit
you so now I spend Christmas with him
Father's Day my birthday with him and
then his birthday too
and then so the fact that I'm so like
far away from all the time makes me more
like hyper aware of like alright I need
to spend more time and I have this rule
that if my dad ever crosses my mind or
even just a dad comes up
conversation I have to message him right
away and tell my love are you not on
your phone also like cute so like we
don't like message all day back and
forth but if you look at our messages
it's like hey I love you I love you too
hey I love you yeah he'll do it first
did you even have a tattoo like imagine
Jesse with your dad yeah that David rhew
and you go marques [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate
you so much so a few years ago I flew my
dad in and my dad's a huge Niners fan
Nikki uh-hmm
who's going to a Super Bowl by the way
this episode comes out people will know
at least we made it oh geez
which is funny cuz half my family is to
choose choose fans good so we're not
having a Super Bowl party for the sake
of the family nobody would know which
ones which so a few years ago I flew my
dad into San Francisco with me and I got
Colin Kaepernick's tattoo artists to do
our matching tattoos so in Vietnamese I
have father in the back of my neck and
my dad has child in his arm
oh so father is bad and child is gone
ceiling and then I posted a picture and
they was like that's a bacon tattoos and
then have like a tattoo on my side also
it's it's a song lyrics to a song that
he used to sing to me when I was a kid
and it's in his handwriting his amazing
calligraphy favorite color that should
hurt - it hurt it hurt it's so sweet
huge daddies I wonder if it is because
like yeah you didn't get to see each
other a lot during childhood and stuff
because I feel like I have such a better
relationship with my dad
now after not living with yeah because
when we live together it was like war we
are too much alike and everyone would
always be like you're just like your dad
which pissed me off more
I thought he was insane and and we would
always butt heads and because he you
know paid all the bills and he's the
elder and you know he does a triage I
wasn't allowed to argue or like say my
piece and you know like I need to say my
piece if I have something to say I'm
pretty outspoken so is he
but because I was the child it was
always like don't talk back shut up
don't say anything and then if I cried
because like out of frustration cuz I
couldn't say anything he'd be like no
crying and he's yell at me for crying
and then it was just like I just hated
living with him and we went like a whole
year in my teenage years without even
talking like we just passed each other
in the kitchen and like not talk but
then when I moved out I was 21 when I
moved out I feel like his soft side came
out like I finally got to see like what
my mom had been talking about all those
years cuz I was always like what soft
side is she talking about she'd be like
he's such a baby in the inside and he
loves you so much and he'd brag about he
brags about you to his work friends and
like in his office he had a bunch of
pictures of me like at work in his work
like I never see those pictures he never
tells me those things but like when I
moved out of the house he started
telling me those things more and I
remember just always just feeling not
good enough for him and feeling like you
know he was never proud of me because he
was a really high standard and so
therefore I had a really high standard
cuz I felt like I couldn't ever meet
this impossible standard but then um
when I was 26 so five years out of the
house we were in New York for a premiere
of something that I was in and he right
before going on like the red carpet he
was like I'm really proud of you planned
that moment in my head so many times
like if he ever said it to me like
actually set it out loud like I would
just start bawling I would hug him and
be like I be wanting you to say that but
because it was right before the my
carpet I would be like Oh what
and he goes I know you don't need to
hear it your brother you hear it all the
time and that's why I tell him you're
like me and we don't need people to tell
us that we just like to get our [ __ ]
done and go and I'm like not true
because he felt like you were so much
like him and so kind of close to him
that he didn't have to so kind of sweet
y'all could be very similar about the
end of the day like we are women we need
a little a little pat on the back every
yeah and also just like if you had had
that conversation with me and childhood
like hey you don't need to be told
actually then at least I would know
intention growing up I was just like I'm
not good enough my brother always gets
told to eat like he makes everyone proud
cause your brother's a [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
the [ __ ] favorite I'm the only
girl so here we married I don't know
wait times because my dad's a pimp you
guys know what he looks like um but he
bed is kind of fun we flash a photo of
Gina's dad but as they call him that
when he was younger they called the
agent Johnny Depp oh [ __ ] the o-line was
[ __ ] wild dude yeah so but he's found
the one now hi mom so I'm the only girl
and I'm the oldest one too
so it's it's really interesting because
like my brothers are soft you know and
and it's because what the weird thing is
it's because they grew it was my dad and
since my dad couldn't raise me he's like
extra nice to them
oh they grew up to be really soft and
then I'm just like what is going on here
I was talking to my friend about I'm
like dude like I'm a stone-cold [ __ ]
these guys I got brass knuckles in my
purse these guys are my friends like
well to be honest you know you're more
of a man that a lot of guys so cute
because my dad has a soft side too yeah
I remember he came to visit with my mom
and my stepmom and he was like yeah your
mom made me get this stupid can you know
I hate cats stupid [ __ ] thing at home
and before bed I walked by the room and
I hear my dad whispering do you think
the cats okay
so yeah he has a huge soft side too oh
so cute
we feel like we're going in order of
like who loves their dad the most so I'm
gonna go laughs you love my relationship
with my dad is really good too really
strong my dad is my number one my best
friend for life
I hope he's watching this I think that
is your Thanksgiving dinners
Thanksgiving dinners like he makes like
a what doesn't he make like a little
Thanksgiving oh yeah I mean he always so
my dad always shows love through food
that's the way he likes to do it the
most but so my relationship with my dad
I think is so good because I'd actually
didn't grow up with him my parents were
divorced from the time I was a little
kid probably is like 1 or 2 years old or
something before I remember sorry they
were always divorced and I always live
with my mom but as my mom kind of lost
her [ __ ]
she lost her she got off her rocker
like when I was a child my dad actually
basically rescued me
so I never got to see him until like
probably middle school ish I mean there
was some time when I was a baby where I
still got to see him but then my mom
took me and my brother to Ohio ran away
from everything in her whole life
hid from my dad my dad couldn't find us
so there was many many years where I was
not in my dad's life and that really
sucked a lot but then when he finally
found us and he rescued me for my mom
who was on drugs it was like he found
you I think he was using a private
investigator but then also he got into
dedication you got it she's like I'm
gonna find this baby mama generalized
attaboy broom Oh ring
[Applause]
[Laughter]
brunette beautiful do I look like his
sisters and my mom sisters kind of got
together too cuz they realize my mom was
on drugs so but yeah my my dad's always
been like a very stern kind of quiet
doesn't really talk he's not like he's I
don't know in the family he's always
kind of like off to the side like he'll
kind of cook food for everyone and then
kind of just set off to the side but he
shows his love through cooking and stuff
like that but then he like as I was
growing up when he when he finally
rescued me and I got to come live with
him he would do the cutest little things
like he would never be super emotional
but he would do things and it would hit
me emotionally like so he would buy me a
pool even though like well he didn't
have a lot of money but buy me like one
of those little pools for the yarn so
you buy me a pool so I would get to play
in the yard like in the water and stuff
and he would kind of just be sitting up
on the porch kinda like drinking a beer
smoking a cigarette just kind of
watching me and it's just like he wanted
I think he really wanted to show his
love for me but he didn't quite know how
but he did everything he could for me
spoiled me a lot and then now I was an
adult I feel like we're just super close
like we have this weird connection where
it's like we both went through a lot and
he he knows he saved me from a really
bad situation and we just have this bond
that's like so strong it's hard to even
describe it it's like no matter what
happens like we've always had this
really icky tear rock connection I
really like like even that little memory
that you're saying of like you just
splashing around in the pool and he's on
the porch it's like being Obama yeah a
way that you describe it though it feels
like he was so grateful you're that
moment which I really like some parents
aren't there just like get on get on out
there put them floaties on and don't you
die I'll be back in an hour I never got
that feeling from him like oh just go
play yeah I never got that feel it was
like he was so happy that you were there
that even just watching you have fun
meant a lot to him yeah that is super
suit it's really cute when dads don't
really like say or show emotion but they
do it in their own way oh yeah there's
so many ways that I could see like I'm
like oh you love
I feel like I only see it now looking
back you know because as I've been apart
from him for this long now I'm like [ __ ]
I am like him dammit
like where I'm just like like the way I
show love is by helping my people get
better at stuff and I'm like damn it
disappointing I hated that like he liked
the like he was like just always like no
you got to do this no no no you're doing
it wrong like it's like this and I mean
he would always be correct him but he
just really wanted us to like do better
and be like become better and he was a
baseball player and he was on like three
different teams and because I was the
first born child and I was unplanned
I think that he was like well she's
gonna play baseball and and so I was
really it tomboyish when I was younger
and I just like really wanted to be a
baseball player and I was a pitcher and
he would always just like we just throw
the ball he would like correct me on
form forever and like looking back I'm
like oh that was like how he bonded cuz
it was like he wanted me to be a good
athlete and he wasn't being like oh
she's a girl so I'll take it easy on her
he was like no you got it like put this
foot forward and then you got put your
weight into this foot and you got a
shoot straight and got your shoulders
like this and it was just very like
strict but it was his way of being like
she's gonna be the best you know it's
interesting um for my my dad he actually
was the opposite he made a he made sure
he every time we saw each other he told
me how much he loves me he would hug me
and kiss me like he would do he would
verbally like tell me but when it in the
moments when it really mattered and it
really it was like he needed to be there
for me or whatever he wasn't like he
actually didn't show his love through
actions it was always through words and
that's why for me like I had a mixed
relationship with my dad because you
know when like my parents got divorced
when I was seven so from my childhood up
until seven that's when we lived
together but he was an abusive guy like
he put my mom through a lot like he
would he was an alcoholic like you know
he even got like cirrhosis of the liver
when he was older because like that's
how much he drank and he would
apparently
what I hear from stories of the family
and my mom would tell me and even from
his own mouth like he would beat my mom
when when I was a child too like he did
you witness any of that or was it kind
of like you just knew it I I don't ever
remember seeing it I do remember him
getting upset and I do remember my mom
crying a lot and I remember being left
alone a lot because my mom had to go out
and work and my dad was never home like
he'd end up having like his drinking
binges and like spend days at a motel
and like not even come home so he like
now as an adult I could see like who my
dad was
and I could judge him and be like he was
a shitty person he really was but then I
can also like look a little deeper and
actually see his childhood and where he
came from and what he's been through and
I sympathize like a lot and I'm like no
wonder he ended up where he did because
he didn't really have much guidance and
he didn't have a lot of love himself so
I understand why he did those things but
growing up I never saw any of that I was
so blinded to it and because I always
saw my dad and he would always make me
feel so [ __ ] loved through his words
because you know as a child you don't
actually like register the fact that
there are no actions like the fact that
he would leave me after school for hours
when he would say he would come pick me
up
obviously I had things to work through
um but I think is like things like that
I end up at me like abandonment issues
because like I don't know how to process
things like that yet like I'm still
working on it but anyway so that's why I
really loved my dad um because of the
verbal stuff right but then after they
split up and he was gone um because of
the fact that my mom went through so
much she kind of like had like
restraining orders against my dad so I
couldn't really see him [ __ ] sorry you
guys dan that's what this kind of
reminds me of my relationship with my
mom it's like the same thing as with
your dad because my mom would always be
telling me how much she loved me but
then she was always gone leaving me with
babysitters she was always getting drunk
getting high like she was alright so
it's
I totally understand like that feeling
that you have like and I try to fight
for my mom's attention and everything
and I and I knew she loved me should
always be saying it's singing songs to
me when she was there but it was always
like just an instant she was there and
then she was gone yeah it was like she
would love bomb me and then she would
just be gone and drinking and all of
that so it's like I understand that yeah
girl so yeah so because of that up until
like I I my dad would tell me to like I
he would somehow find a way to
communicate with me through an uncle or
something and he would tell me like I
want to see you I can't see you or your
mom is preventing like they really used
me as a weapon to hurt each other during
their divorce you yeah I was just got
for you that's why I hate that for baby
Tiff's and adult if in fact teenage tiff
his wad and old Tiff's I know I hate
that for her thanks girl I mean I'm
working through it obviously there's a
lot more to work to do but I think I've
been ok with a lot of it um anyway so
because of that um I resented my mom a
lot growing up
because I'm I'm like I [ __ ] love my
dad why can't I see my dad it's your
fault I can't see my dad and she would
just tell me like obviously she's hurt I
understand why she would do this but she
would just badmouth my dad a lot and so
that just made me resent her even more
because I'm like why like let me make
that decision for myself like let me see
who my dad is on my own so it ended up
getting to the point where when I was 15
my mom and I was relationship it was
like [ __ ] it was so bad that we would
fight all the time so we got to the
point where she she was like you know
what just go to Mexico and live with you
it cuz my dad was in Mexico that's the
reason why I wouldn't see him that much
but you were born there like one year in
America oh yes that's why I ended up
spending that one year in Mexico when I
was 15 and that one year I was supposed
to be with my dad but he would just he
would be gone all the time exactly
people he pawned me off a lot and that's
ended up being with my sister's a lot
but but yeah then in that time that's
when I really got to see who he was and
really like realize like oh this is the
person that you are this is the type of
father that you are like I've always
believed that you loved me and yes you
keep saying it but yeah you're not
showing it with your actions so then by
the time I hit adulthood like I guess I
still kind of had that veil in my eyes
where I'm like oh my god I love you so
much still no matter what has happened
no matter cuz we had never gone in an
argument he has never made me actually
like feel bad ever so that's why I like
I don't know the last time I saw him
that was the only time we did get into
an argument and and then like hands up
disappearing and so now I don't really
have a conclusion yeah I don't have
closure so yeah he's been um he's been
missing for two years and there's just
been really hard dealing with it because
I it's just because of the fact that
there's no closure I don't know what to
do with that relationship in my life you
know like like I said like I have
abandonment issues and then like I I
don't know it's just I'm a mess I don't
know I'm really curious of it because I
know that when we went to the Mahna
concert that was really like emotional
for us it gives you a good memory of
your dad yeah do you feel like really
conflicted in that exactly that's why I
that that's why I said like I feel like
I'm in the middle because that little
girl that little tiff that saw her dad
as a hero like she's still very much
alive within me and that's why when I
went to my nine like I had that
connection like I it's that little girl
inside that's coming out and saying like
I [ __ ] love my dad like my dad is my
hero he's my rock on everything and but
then the adult tiff comes in and
realizes who she knows he's not quite
right exactly yeah being in the middle
is hard except for last night when I was
in the middle of my comforter my
mattress I wasn't like I'm tearing up
for Tiffany and I'm just now just do you
need some comfort you do well I wish we
had a puppy in studio for you but I've
been taking them all home that's right
guys
[ __ ] wait wait you guys talk about
that segue because I felt like it was
pretty good guys I have been I have been
like the spokeswoman the man the myth
the legend the most excited person ever
for the Buffy I just got my baby back
from the cleaners yesterday dude
yesterday the cleaners four times in my
life and I literally just started going
for my Buffy like I want it to be in the
most top-quality
condition it's white they bleach it
perfect get all the stains out it's
worth it it's worth it it is by far the
most comfortable comforter I've ever had
in my layers I don't want to dude
everybody has one is my favorite comfort
of all time I'd say that the best way I
can describe it is you don't know when
you're on a hotel trip and you finally
get in your hotel bed you're like this
is amazing it's not the mattress it's
not the hotel it's the freakin comforter
really it the comforter is what makes a
bed so amazing how do I get one of these
invest in Buffy and you're probably
wondering what is Buffy Buffy makes a
supersoft earth-friendly bedding and
because a comfy night's sleep is even
comfier when it doesn't harm the
environment it's not made out of a tree
who knew so Buffy makes the Earth's most
comfortable bedding adding me everything
is made from ultra smooth eucalyptus
fiber that feels softer than cotton it
really is
eucalyptus fiber is breathable and cool
to the touch to help maintain the ideal
sleeping temperature and feel cozy
without overheating that's why I like it
because I'll be sweating like really
that's not gross its natural all their
products are cruelty free and
hypoallergenic people lower
it has a 4.6 star rating 20,000 reviews
that is such a high average what has
20,000 free trial you can try to
configure your obit for free and if you
don't love it you can return it at no
cost so for $20 off your Buffy comforter
visit Buffy CO and enter mood once again
for $20 off your Buffy comforter that's
Buffy CO and into the code mood at
checkout hallelujah and when I get my
Buffy I smile really use braces to get
my smile this straight but I wish I
didn't because this technology was not
available for me when I was in high
school but it is for you because Candida
candied co has these clear aligners that
you don't need to have this ugly-ass
Braceface bracelet you can take a mom
can't please stop attacking me okay a
headgear when I was a kid oh my god I
had nothing where you it like widens
your mouth your nerd I even tried to get
the clear of bands so that it didn't
look as obvious oh my god so unlike
braces candid clear aligners are
comfortable removable and totally
invisible so you can transform your
smile without anyone noticing a thing
you never have to set foot in a doctor's
office or a waiting room which is also
awesome cuz I who likes doing that I
hate driving too so like that's it I'm
just getting in the mail you get your
treatment prescribed remotely by a
licensed orthodontist and Candida livers
everything you need right to your door
and unlike other companies canon only
works with orthodontists never general
dentists so that means your treatment
will be designed by an expert in tooth
with 20 years of experience on average
if you're you know looking forward to a
special event you can get the average
treatment length is only six months so
you'll start seeing results basically
like right away it's the simplest freest
way to get started on straight teeth so
my gonna if you're ready to take the
first step toward straighter teeth
limited time you can get started with us
seventy five dollars off by using code
mood at candid code calm / mood that's
can encode calm / mood code mood for $75
off can
cocom food code mood yes 75
mother-freaking dollars off yeah I'm
freaking dollars off daddy's Bo's
daddy's oh you haven't gotten to your
daddy get what happened
how about told any of you guys about my
dad told me a little bit but it's really
like it's your baby on a JK news as all
girls episode so I know we were all in
that okay wait how come don't years ago
she opened up to us we drank that night
yeah I know I don't know why part mint
Eliza's in my mind but she called her
dad and was like why did you leave right
one time this [ __ ] quite a few
times
oh no look I'm gonna try to like I want
to give you guys a bunch of information
but also I don't want to hog up too much
of the time but I feel like there are so
many people out a lot of time they
didn't grow up with their dads like
single mothers and then also there's a
lot of guys out there that are listening
and like I can tell you what my
perspective of it is if you [ __ ]
leave so my my dad was a my dad was kind
he was a chef he was like a TV chef TV
show TV chef I mean he never lived for
his name I'm gonna go look him on I did
anything like too too too crazy but like
80s 90s he was a TV chef he was also a
bartender in Washington DC so he was
just cool hip he's like part black like
part Native American and then like part
European so he was a little exotic and
with Obama except for me he was a
bartender he could cook so my mom my dad
met and like he really would her but
this man was also an alcoholic and he
was not ready to settle down by any
means
my mother sometime in her late twenties
had a tumor on her ovaries that was
about the size of a grapefruit like when
they found out about it and so she had
half of her reproductive system removed
or like some large portion of it and I
don't know I don't know like I do
know that that was a thing so plot twist
my mom gets [ __ ] pregnant with me
with this dude maybe so she doesn't
think she can get pregnant and I I'm not
sure I never asked her too much about
this I just know that that maybe she
thought she was fine as a factor though
like maybe she wasn't expecting you yeah
yeah but I know that she really I think
that she I know she really liked my dad
was really interested in him and wanted
him to settle down and like he he wasn't
ready he was a hot bartender in DC that
was he was a [ __ ] boy like my dad was
literally kind of a [ __ ] boy and so my
mom had other suitors that were really
interested in her and there was one guy
and this kind of like really hurt me
when I was younger but obviously she
didn't do it it was this one guy that
really liked her that she worked with
and he wanted to date my mom and he told
her he was like please don't have this
child I will pay you money to like have
the abortion and also like to help you
out and not have this kid and my mom
said no because this is miracle baby and
she's also like very religious and she
had me and I don't really know my dad's
perspective on it but he was not around
I think he might have been there for
when I was delivered but after that he
went back up to DC and he just never
really likes to real for him he was like
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah he never really came
back around and you know as I got older
like I'm like where's my dad where's my
dad but my mom was like she was always
there always always there so I guess I
didn't think that much and then also my
grandpa was a very prominent male figure
in my life like anything I needed like
my grandpa was there he was basically my
dad but it started to become very real
to me that I was lacking this
relationship with my father like when I
went to school when I would see other
people with their kids or what their
dads and my mom would always invite him
to come down and visit and he would just
never come like I would there there was
like one time that like I had the smiley
face shirt and he was supposed to come
visit and my mom was like why did you
pick that shirt and I said because I
want daddy to see how happy I am to see
him and I still remember waiting in the
doorway like I remember like waiting in
the doorway for him to pull up and I was
just I was like he's gonna pull up at
any second like I still remember
standing there and he just never called
and he never came and I and this was
maybe the third or the fourth time that
had done this and I decided that I was
done like I was done he was no longer
old Rio this time
I don't know yeah I was like I was like
we're we're done you're excused cancel
oh yeah he was canceled and and I and I
I remember at a very young age
completely shutting myself down to that
because I wasn't gonna let this guy hurt
me anymore I and I my heart was not open
for him
in fact I shut out a lot about people
after that too because I realized how
deeply I could be hurt I'm a very
sensitive person so I went on and on
without him and I was fine I never hear
a lot stronger than me I never thought
about it I never really thought about
him again
like very rarely and so my relationship
with my dad just continued to like
decline I I went out there for one
summer to visit tissues and um I don't
need no damn tissue if you don't want to
clench your butthole oh really
we lost them so we so you know I do die
I said it down hard and I remember like
your boy was fine like I was [ __ ]
fine because when you when you shut that
part out it doesn't really hurt anymore
and so then I did one summer where I
went to visit him he's a weird dude he's
like growing weed plants and [ __ ] he was
real funny
we laughed the same we had like without
having contact with each other we were
so similar how did that connection and
happen again no I really don't remember
so you've always been you've always had
a way to contact him but you guys never
really know no real interest I think
from either parties um when I finally
decided to visit him it was because my
friend did I wanted a vacation and he
offered to fly us both up there and just
stay with him for the summer and it was
in a really really really really really
nice place it was at Martha's Vineyard
Martha's Vineyard suppose making money
no no no that's where I'm part Wampanoag
and my tribe is from there so so yeah so
we visited him
didn't really think too much of it I was
like all right sick went back home and I
man I was just so shut off it just
really didn't do much for me but um I
I'm trying to like even think what
happened so sometimes so for a long time
it I was really shut off but deep down
inside you can shut your heart down but
something still hurts sometimes and
there would be times where something bad
would happen
like and my environment issues would
trigger again and I would immediately
blame him so I think that's where am I
calling him would happen sometimes
because he was the root of it and I was
I didn't want him but I was angry with
him that he planted this seed in me that
affected me at such an young age I grew
into this poison in my life that was
affecting my other relationships I was
very angry with him for that but um a
few years like years and years later
sometime when I was in my 20s I had a
guy friend I had a guy friend and he got
a girl pregnant and he didn't and also
my dad never paid any child support no
nothing he what did your mom make him
she's actually something you said was
really interesting to me you said that
your mom always blamed your dad my mom
never really spoke ill of my father she
never really did she was very um Noack
she yeah I mean that that was the best
way to do it because you have such a
close relationship with your mom yes she
was a very aware of that I never I never
thought about that this she didn't she
didn't talk [ __ ] about I'm she I mean
he's obviously a piece of [ __ ] he's an
alcoholic but she didn't really talk
badly of him um at least to me so we so
might have this friend that gets a girl
pregnant in like in he's in his early
20s and he's like I can't have this kid
like I told her I don't want to be a dad
I'm not ready to be a dad like I can't
do this and I agreed with him I was like
you are not ready to be a dad I'm like
you need to like communicate this with
her like maybe chef C and abortion but
you guys need to pay for it like you
need to really figure this out well he
wanted to have the kid no matter what
and he was devastated
he was absolutely devastated he didn't
want to marry her he didn't he's [ __ ]
this is my son he didn't know what to do
so he peaced out and he just paid the
child support and I got it like I got it
in that moment that my dad was not ready
to have a child he wanted to live his
life he was still a young guy he was
bartending he's getting [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] getting money like he's having the
time of his life and then now you have
this kids it's three hours away that you
didn't really ask for and you know and
and I got it it wasn't me it was not me
he didn't know me and so like write me
off right I could never take it so
personally he was just selfish and
wanted to live his life and I I forgave
him and I understood because I knew what
my guy friend was going for so fast
forward to today that's honestly my
relationship with my dad like not not
everyone takes it that way but the kind
of sad part that we're at now is it he
never wanted really anything to do with
me for the longest time and it told you
guys he was a TV chef so he was like
kind of famous he was in entertainment
he's funny that's where my extraversion
comes from and then suddenly I'm on
YouTube and I'm doing all this stuff I I
have a red carpet picture he would
always ask me to like send pictures and
stuff and he starts realizing like wait
like my daughter's killing it like she's
she's she must be a big deal and then
suddenly he wants to call me all the
time suddenly he wants all of my most
recent pictures he wants to post all my
pictures he's like look at my baby
he's like posting these on Facebook he's
sending these do that you know he's uh
he he's asking me how much money am i
makin how much is this and where he's
out right now is he owns he not owns he
had like a [ __ ] small food truck or
something and he drives uber and he
sells weed straight-up that's what he's
doing and I even if I wanted to forge a
relationship with my father I'm
terrified of having to take care of him
I'm terrified of having to pay for his
retirement fund that does not exist I'm
terrified of having to fly him out and
him wanting to live with me I don't know
his wife I'm not close with her and you
know when I when I make my first million
when your boy makes it every single
dollar that I have to spare and you know
in excess is going to my mother right
and taking care of my mother it was
always there I will put her in a golden
retirement home
that overlooks the whole city and every
extra dollar I have is going to her it
is not going to him so I've kind of had
to make a difficult choice to really
kind of cut him off in the past year
because I don't want to get close I
don't want to be obligated I don't want
to like because you're like an an
emotionally vulnerable place and like if
you do get close to him it might it
might be like out of your hands but you
might kind of fall for him again as your
dad and then wind up sort of being taken
advantage of yeah literally being taken
advantage there's no reason for you to
ask what kind of money I'm making or for
you to you know like ask what my
boyfriend's career is or for you to you
know it really concerned me when I
started hearing a lot about money or I
want more red carpet photos you know
this is sometimes he was like he was
like hey he was like hey I want to send
you some money for Christmas and I was
like all right here's my PayPal thanks
bye like you still chipping away for
that child support that you never paid
like oh I'll take it if you're offering
it but he also he doesn't have much so I
never really you know if it's my
birthday I and he's like all I want to
send you something I'm like nah dude
we're good you know but every now and
then if he offers I'll be like sure why
not I mean the man hasn't paid me paid
me or my mother probably more than
$1,500 in my entire life
you know yeah she took care of
everything the reason why my dad went to
Mexico cuz after they split up and they
went to court and there was like a child
support that he had to pay he was
running from the corner and it's just
going to the wife and they are you know
and they hate the woman so much and
they're so over that woman they're like
I'm not giving you my money like it's
not even about her yeah I know that's my
dad had a key popped out with more other
kids too like I think I my son is older
than two of his uncle's was crazy man
and uncle yeah
Oh like I have half siblings yeah I
forgot my my dad I was not the first
victim my dad had a he was actually
married before and I have a half-sister
that
never met before I've spoken to her on
the phone twice in my entire life and
when I heard her voice for the first
time I [ __ ] cried because she sounded
just like me like just the way she spoke
and she and I have started to connect a
little bit more like not that much but
she doesn't want to hear my dad's name
at all she doesn't want to hear anything
about him and she was like one day we'll
hang out and get wasted and talk mad
[ __ ] about it and I'm like so down but
yeah like we've never met before
did you have any type of relationship at
all with him no she was not blessed in
the way that I was that that my mom
never drove a wedge between my dad and I
because she knew how important a
relationship between a child and a
father should be but my sister is mom
really drove a wedge you must go I mean
it's good and bad because I mean you
have those very very hurtful moments I
like waiting for him to pick you up and
like him never doing that but for her
it's kind of like she just is just a
ghost she never got hurt so it's hard
for me to decide like what's the right
choice as a woman you know with a child
it's like well for me personally I ended
up because I was on one end of the
spectrum where it's my mom talking [ __ ]
about my dad and net that made me resent
my mom and have a bad relationship with
my mom I decided to never ever play that
role in my son's life like I have tried
my best like I been very conscious to
never talk ill of his father to like
force them to go in there like have a
relationship like that's great like ever
since he was a baby to like I would
always be like dude you have to come and
see your son you have to like you have
to have a relationship with him you have
to pick them up and you you need to be
in his life so it's like you go pick him
up you're not gonna leave him waiting
he's all happy to see you she's having
flashbacks to little tiff whenever I
picture a little tiff I imagined her
with blue hair
[Applause]
it's it's interesting too I mean it
makes sense like us as adults now being
the age our parents were when they you
know had us like had little baby us as
running around to empathize with them
and all the things that didn't make
sense when we were kids you kind of are
like oh I understand now and I empathize
because I feel like my dad was like it
was like the other way it could have
gone where you know I was not planned
and my mom was only 21 when she got
pregnant with me and he was 23 and so
they had me very very young and at that
time my dad had just gotten like kicked
out of college he was playing baseball
he's getting scouted by baseball teams
and like he was wanted to be a
professional ballplayer and and then I
come along and he basically had to
choose between like being a dad or going
moving to Arizona and playing baseball
and so he chose like being a dad which I
really respect him for and I'm grateful
for now but because when I was a kid he
all he wanted to do was play baseball he
was on like three different teams I
hardly ever saw him unless we were there
at the baseball game and then he would
be getting drunk all night with his
friends and just you know being a young
20 young twenties guy and I didn't you
know get that like as a kid it was like
why is he never one to spend time with
me you know but and then when he would
spend time he'd be like kind of angry
and I wouldn't get it but he was really
[ __ ] stressed like he was having to
balance being a twenty-something guy and
then completing college he was like okay
I'll go back to school
I'll get my degree he got his degree I
was at his graduation when I was four
when he graduated and got his bachelor's
degree and then when I was in like
junior high or high school when he went
back and got his master's to become a
CPA and he did all that as like that was
his plan B and he would always tell me
like you got to have a plan B you got to
get your degree you
I had that security because imagine if I
had just pursued being a baseball player
and then I wouldn't be able to take care
of the family so he really relied on
principle and I really like that and I
think that's where we're similar is the
like owning responsibility and not
making excuses and not like being
selfish if we like if we did something
to own it and to you know take
responsibility for it
but because he was so caught up in like
the security factor of it like oh you
got to get your degree to it like
because what if something happens when I
said I wanted to drop out of school to
you know be an actor is when he was like
oh no also probably a little bit of him
is like no I couldn't do that you're not
gonna do that you know you would have
these conversations like you gotta
follow your passion gotta follow your
passion he's like wait wait but you also
you wanted you to be like well-rounded
it's my uh my dad was my dad was in my
dad was in school for a long time okay
he was in school for a long what do you
mean what I feel like there's a subtext
here he was in school for a long time
that's all you're getting
and like is this like a criminal thing
or like he or he was hella beause he's a
scholar I'm trying to figure out what
school emo got like a master's yeah he
was just [ __ ] wild back then right and
then so when he was in school he right
right he he went to school right after
my mom was pregnant with me and then he
did a complete 180 like when he was
sitting in school school of hard knocks
him she was like [ __ ] I have a daughter
now and usually like it's people don't
change you know but when he found out I
have a daughter a complete 180 like I'm
talking like now the man has a business
a big house a family like wow the only
thing that gives it away is the way he
looks
you know if he's always tattoos and
stuff so the like knowing that just
makes me like I'm so proud of him like
long proud daughter you know and because
because people they don't a lot of times
that doesn't work out you know
and yeah I respect it so much because I
asked someone like so he lives with this
constant regret of not being able to get
food as fast as he was you know like he
had to eat in the cafeteria and it was
terrible but you know what he wish he
had door dad do you have big plans for
2020 or when you get out of school yeah
big plans for when you get out of school
but no time to really make out well with
door - you could just get food delivered
right to your door it's in the name it's
pretty obvious what it does right yes
order delivery
yeah with door - you take back time in
your day because yeah you know you want
to say that time dude it's so great like
I just lay there just veg out in my robe
just like drooling and then that
doorbell goes off and it's my doorbell
no I got one of those fancy camera ones
there's [ __ ] door - at my door exact
word a door delivery in all 50 US states
without equal canada australia australia
damn you can order from your local and
go to or choose from your favorite
national restaurants like just old
windows like taking a bowl a cheesecake
factory with door - with door - you'll
never have to worry about your next meal
yeah they have over three hundred and
ten thousand restaurants and partners
with four thousand cities so you will
you will definitely find your favorite
restaurant so yes yes order that right
now our listeners can get five dollars
off their first order of $15 or more
when you download the door - app and
enter promo code big food that's five
dollars off your first order when you
download the door - app in the App Store
and enter promo code big mooing Moo yes
don't forget one that's promo code big
mode for five dollars off your first
order and right after you order that
food it's time to relax
you had a real agitation or possibly
sleep and how do you get some better
relaxation meditation or sleep but the
comm app yeah exactly
the calm app is actually one of my
favorite apps I've been on it for three
or four years yeah yeah I've had it for
a long-ass time and I loved it her voice
just like instantly puts me in this very
medical that's why it's the number one
app for sleep and relaxation and
meditation cuz it has sleep stories do
you have a favorite a favorite sleep
story yeah no I actually don't I don't
use it for sleep I use it for stress
because I'm constantly stressed out and
I like how they have their daily calm
where it's a 10-minute meditation and
she gives you a little like something to
think about for your day and it's
usually accompanied by a story like a
little like blurb of like why that that
why you should think about that
throughout your day like hey we're not
all perfect and you know that in Japan
they had these faces that are filled in
with gold cracks because like it
celebrates the flaws and I'm like oh
[ __ ] I gotta celebrate my flaws if
celebrities don't read you stories and
I've been really advocating for a
Gilbert Godfried oh my god that would
listen to a story about like lavender
fields and it did put me to sleep and I
didn't have a dream about lavender field
oh that's I'm so call me it was my
favorite thing is actually the master
classes that they have on that okay
they'll have like someone doing lectures
and it's like like ten part lectures and
I would like that part okay so she's the
one with the Masters of the show calm is
offering a special limited time
promotion of 40% off a common a Tom calm
slash mood that's 40% off unlimited
access to calms entire library and new
content is added every week so get
started today at com.com slash mood
that's com.com slash mood you sit on
down and relax girl um have you any of
you guys have like a stepdad situation
cuz a lot of people end up oh oh my god
I forgot about him but I really like him
he's bad cool like I okay wait so yeah I
had a stepdad come into my life around
like 15 or so and it was when I was at
like my absolute worst it was really
weird because my my mom and my stepdad
thought that like I didn't like him or
like I was mad at him and reality like I
[ __ ] hated everybody like oh I wanted
everyone to die like 15 I was like my
absolute like I ran away from home a few
times and like my and I so there was a
time that my mom thought this because
like I um
she's probably stopped listening by now
so I can say this so I had run away from
home and when I when I came I've like
remember this when I came back it was um
it was the first time my mom cried and
I'd never seen her like cry over me
before she was just always like very
very like stoic she felt like she had to
be the strong one for us but in turn she
didn't like show enough emotion and
there was one time that like when I ran
away I told her because you don't need
me anymore and so she thought that like
I felt like she thought that I was like
saying like you guys don't need me you
have each other but I was moreso saying
[ __ ] you are so sensitive I felt like I
had to stay around because you would
just crumble like otherwise like I knew
that my mom was always putting on a
strong face but she's such a [ __ ]
softie and I felt like I couldn't leave
her I felt like that I had to be there
for her too and so when my set thought
comes in the picture I was like oh thank
god he'll take care of her and so like
when I told her this like she really
thought that like I didn't like him for
the longest time but like I always loved
the guy and he he takes amazing care of
my mom and he started to show me that's
one thing that's really important like
with a dad a dad shows you as a young
girl how you should be treated and it
teaches you like things about men one of
the worst things that's happened to me
my entire life or throughout my life is
that I didn't understand men a lot of
times like you guys like lived with your
dad's for a while if something really
like sad happens at school or drama or
something you run over into your dad's
lab and you're like dad and he's just
like no what are you talking about I
never had that so I didn't know that men
don't want to hear about that [ __ ] they
don't I didn't get to learn what men
care about in women
so when I started having relationships
they were really bad because I didn't
know I didn't know how to have a
relationship with a man I had no idea I
didn't have one so when this guy comes
in my life around 15 I started to see
how a wife and husband act around the
house and what they do and I saw him
always taking care of her and like I was
so grateful that like finally I didn't
have to take care of her anymore
but also that he was doing such a good
job and she was so happy and I felt like
she was in good hands
so I moved out at like my mom and I were
at war a lot for the longest time but
like I moved out at 17 I moved out again
at 20 I moved that again at 22 like and
then I finally moved out again to LA and
it it like calms me down so much that he
can take care of her because I don't
know if you guys don't have single moms
at all or any of you guys have single
moms it hurts you to leave your mother
it really really does like she needs to
be like taking care of you want somebody
there to like you know keep it together
and like that's what my stepdad was for
me he was never like he was never like
oh my god you're my dad
like until more recently but he was
there to protect and take care of my mom
and I needed that so that I could be
free and go out and spread my wings
we'll call CPS on them that's how you
are as a good friend to ask how
relationships and dads affect your
relationships with them and I'm glad
that Beau's talking about that because
that is I feel like you do because my
relationship with men is like I don't
need you it really did like it's always
been like I don't do that yeah the fact
that my relationship with my dad is so
good and he's like treats me like a
princess kind of ruins it a little bit
for my relationship with Ben because I'm
like how dare you not do this for me
already like do you know who I
daddy's girl as a man you should be
doing this you know and they're just
like I'm not your dad yeah like child
yeah like I was compared Joe a lot of
times too I'm like well my dad would
just do that for me and Joe's like daddy
issues out of here I expect too much
from it I have a high standard yeah so I
feel like that's good but I think I
think I still have the it's like you
it's similar because I do have mommy
issues so I still have bad relationships
in general because I just like I don't
trust people a lot of times I have the
fear of abandonment still but like with
a man it's it's different it looks like
based off of what you discard with your
dad your dad would just he genuinely
felt so lucky to be in your prime so now
where's my coffee and my cigarette I'm a
spoiled not that's well that's really so
we have this thing where whenever I come
home like I said he still treats me like
a kid he'll like what my mom's not
looking he's like here I have some money
for you you take you when I'm like 30
years old guys I don't care you're
always gonna be my baby oh yeah yeah
it's me like a wad of cash and I'm I
always leave um like I always fly home
in the afternoon what my dad's working
so I sneak back into his room and I hide
money in there and then some more and
it's become like this constant back and
forth game it's adorable like I hate
things like my mom doesn't know and I'm
just like like he'll hide in the room or
like he'll pull me aside that could be
somebody I'm like it's really cute but
like what I was saying earlier since he
didn't have like we didn't grow up
together
he lives like this constant regret of
like I didn't raise you I'm a terrible
father only and I'm like dead dude
you're [ __ ] dope you know like from
how you changed your life so what it is
now
is nearly like impossible for a lot of
people you know so it's been like a
really he still has those thoughts
whenever I see him like [ __ ] cool
like well he's like watching TV and I
just lay there with my head on his lap
like hey Dad did you ever like with Tim
on your mom's side like did she ever
have someone on her in her life where
you would see as like sort of stepdad uh
no my mom god she's how do I put this my
mom a lot of mommy issues here
so she is you know like I always make it
a joke like I'm a [ __ ] a B G like
they go on a party my mom is the
original like she had been to a B G she
a super fine I want to see your mom
she's aged very well and she's always
been really pretty and she's still about
that life like she goes off her friends
on the weekends she like loves Hennessy
and all that [ __ ] he was hiking with our
friends and takes photos I just want one
time to go party with your mom okay so
here's the thing
even if it's ratchet I don't care I
wanna go party with your mom yeah so the
thing with my mom is we got along when
we were younger and like we took her
clubbing like oh so cool I'm going
clubbing with my mom was [ __ ] that
was when I was 21 and then now I'm just
like alright you feel older than your
mom now yeah that's right so your mom
was the type that just had boyfriends so
she yeah so she was only one genus just
like to have fun I know and I was fine
with that when I was younger I was like
okay well she had me she was like 20
dude yeah she's making up for it you
know and I'm now it's just like all
right come on you're yeah you still have
the club it's getting like it's cool for
a few years now it's kind of like an
embarrassing too many years you know so
we got a long one we were younger
because I understood and then she
started getting more and more like like
she would tell my sibling me and my
siblings like what are you guys just
gonna like move and go out I want to do
my own thing
and it's just like dude what the [ __ ]
you know so she was almost more like a
birth giver but not necessarily a mom
yeah a derogatory term your support
the best-looking birth giving out there
like we have moments where it's like
it's really sweet you know like I used
to when I was all beat up it was a
teenager whenever I went to go visit
with her wouldn't we'd sleep I just like
hold her hand cuz we like I want to
sleep in the same bed as her so it was
fine but then after a while I'm just
like hey like you can't be treating your
kids like they're burdens to your
partying life you know where your
[ __ ] kids I remember she would tell
us like oh I'm telling that you're my
sister oh my gosh
we don't yeah we don't really hear about
that there are a lot of women that
should not have had kids yeah and we
always hear like the guys being pieces
of [ __ ] but there are a lot of piece of
[ __ ] women too it should not have had
kids you got a lot to say huh oh yeah oh
damn mommy I kind of feel like a little
bit too I'm afraid of having kids
because of like how shitty my mom was
and I don't have a guy in my life that
seems as stable as my dad as calm as my
dad as like understanding and like
willing to like sacrifice their lives um
you're gonna marry a guy that seriously
dude like like my dad I would wake up
and my dad would have pink [ __ ]
frosted doughnuts waiting for me on the
kitchen counter and like made look guy
no no me if a guy doesn't wake like if I
don't wake up in the yeah I think I dad
set the standard yeah like way too hard
ever found out that I see that something
is like my dad wasn't like didn't treat
me like a princess but he was very much
like through actions like he liked to
take care of me like financially secure
like security wise which I resented as a
child because I was like when I grow up
and make my own money you won't be able
to control me because I felt like he
would almost be like it's my money my
rules you know and it was really just he
wanted us to be safe and taken care of
and he would make jokes about like like
when I moved out he'd be like well I'm
still paying your health insurance you
know this what are you gonna start
paying your health insurance and anyway
he doesn't want you to barely started
paying all of the bills he kind of got
sad
juice anymore that's funny because we
you guys are saying it's like your dad
set the standard cuz you have very high
standards for men you have astronomical
standards for me and in mine is like
basic [ __ ] time listen to everything
I say in a conversation I'm like well
just drop those trousers funny so my dad
is like yours um so my dad's Vietnamese
obviously right my stepmom is white and
it's the funniest thing I had to teach
my dad how to date my mom my stepmom
because he is all about like
everything's taken care of I pay the
bills if you need something to take the
credit card go you know like that's how
he shows love right and that's how I
show love to him like here I bought you
something I took care of everything good
my mom's white dates and flowers right
and it was so funny because my dad and
my stepmom kind of split up for a little
bit because she was lacking that and
that he was just destroyed well I can't
I did like an emergency fly-in Oh like
oh he liked right he the fool didn't
even know how to like heat up a pizza Oh
an oven he literally just popped a
frozen pizza in there just turn it on
just stared at no preheating or anything
cardboard boxes no you so lost without
her he was like I need to get her back
and so I had a date and it was all
motifs thing I'm like this like 27 year
old kid like teaching him how to date
and then I was like okay and he's like
she's she sent me a heart on Facebook
what do I say
oh it was really cute and he's like no
you type it you type it I was like okay
you need to give her space and then just
say okay goodnight I love you and he
goes and then ask her can I come see
your deaf adorable I love her I want to
be your dad and then like he goes I have
a date with her next week oh I was like
did you get her flowers he goes she got
her flowers but yes you get her flowers
and then like the next thing was like we
have an overnight date Oh gross yeah
[Applause]
- my congratulations like he's like okay
do what I say block like and the next
thing I call he's like I'm at the mall I
hate the mall mom he's like yes I'm like
good job daddy you know they're finally
back together and I talked to my stepmom
and then it's just like this really
funny like she's like 15 years younger
than him and she's white so she wants
like the lovey-dovey in the dates my dad
has no idea how to do that like this is
the first woman where he's like I love
her and I'll do this for her you know he
must be good in bed cuz like if she's
not getting that yeah you hear that
Jeana your dad must be good if someone
told me she was like you know we have to
get your aunt to do our taxes for a
while for the business but we had to
stop and I'm doing it now I'm like why
she goes cuz it was really interesting
explaining some write-offs I'm like well
what do you mean she goes um she called
my my your aunt called one day and asked
what is this charge from Adam and Eve
calm wait and I projectile-vomited need
to tell me these things you don't know
Adam and Eve is not cancelled yeah dude
Gina you said something really really
interesting there though about how your
Wow after the breakup like your dad
didn't have feed him soft and I made
impossible so ladies don't forget pack
is lunch every day making my completely
useless thing is though the thing is and
this is funny my stepmom told me she's
like god you're so you're [ __ ] dead
because even though I didn't grow up
with him for some reason we ended up
exactly the same yeah same yeah yes so
you know he said to me he's when when
they broke up he was like you know the
thing is I'm not afraid that I'll lose
her forever like she won't come back I'm
afraid that I won't need her anymore and
okay I'm fine with that you know I mean
like I don't want to not want someone
anymore
like get used to not having her around
cuz that's how I am I was like okay
alright that's a little bit opposite of
what I thought it would be but okay so
he wasn't afraid of oh she won't love me
more it's just I'm afraid of going back
to my old ways and not
needing anyone anymore yeah dude we
should have you know what we should have
like for a guest on this episode we
should know like an alternative
perspective we should have had somebody
on that was a planned child because it
appears don't go into the entertainment
industry doctors trial but Oh true oh
yeah you did one teenager that was 17
and I was like yeah let's have a baby
oh my god Isaac's a little worried
oh yeah well interview Isaac I'm being a
plan child so what's it like being
planned I want to talk to somebody that
their parents at like in their early 30s
we're like let's have a baby together we
have a house already we both have our
career samples like how did they turn
any of y'all planned children what was
it like having both parents in the
picture but guys dude but whenever
you're in the middle of that hot steamy
lovemaking wrapped a [ __ ] up because
you might hatch one of us and then you
got it [ __ ] for the rest of your alive
I'm going to entertainment and [ __ ]
millions are kids Instagram and it looks
like they have the best time but they're
calling you like can you buy me a pizza
is that the one thing we all have in
common that we're like not really
playing yeah my brother was planned I
could call him he's a bomber now here's
a regular job he's a kid yeah well we
had something to prove
we were like somebody somebody needs to
do that they need to have they needed to
have a controlled experiment three three
different children one that's completely
planned one where one of the parents
leaves and then one that's just like a
total accident from a one-night stand
I'm so cool and children are boring
sorry so basic I know plan one he's like
he's like a great career and it's like
his parents all have that guy boring
they take like Christmas photos secure
relationships
hug your daddies hug your mommies let us
know in the comments what Dad are you
the commies are you we can't all shout
out a message to our dads this week
great can you start all at the same time
one two no that would have been my
message I have nothing like I'll let
[ __ ] please see you next time share this
with your friends sherry I've seen so
many people on Twitter they'll be like
oh what's a good podcast listen to and
some of you guys go in and you respond
to them we hit you back on the big mood
account
Thank You sherry buddies oh yeah our
first time first March versus really
this really first time there's a really
hot girl it took a picture of herself
half-naked watching big mood and it
always saw that one yeah Xena the
warrior princess yeah right yeah oh love
you guys
[Music]